- Hi, my name's Zack.
There's a new dating
site called Mouse Mingle
where Disney fans can meet-up.
I'm gonna see what happens when I use
actual Disney lines to
pick-up real people.
You know, winter's a good
time to stay in and cuddle.
It's your hairdo, right?
You've been using the dinglehopper?
- What? (laughs)
- I know you.
I walked with you once upon a dream.
- [Man in black shirt] Sure.
- [Zack] No wait.
Come back.
Please come back!
- [Bearded man] What's up?
- [Zack] I don't even know
your name, how will I find you?
- [Bearded man] Oh, you don't need to.
- Oh, okay.
So some people are worth melting for,
but maybe just not right this second.
- Oh, that's funny. (laughs)
- Do you ever wonder what those
sparkly dots are up there?
- What sparkly dots?
- [Zack] Why do you shut me out?
Why do you shut the world out?
What are you so afraid of?
- [Woman in red] I don't know.
- Join me for dinner.
That was not a request!
- [Man in hoodie] What?
- What do you say me
and you take a walk over
to the tavern and look at my trophies?
- That sounds like a good idea.
- Thank you. (woman laughs)
This is the day your dreams come true!
I'm going to be king of Pride Rock.
- I don't speak English.
- Oh. (man laughs)
("Fantasy Dreamworld" by Audio Network)